How are you, sir?
Oh, well, you, I'm good. Thank
you.
Causing trouble today. Uh, it's been a good day.
That means you've been causing trouble.
I staying outta trouble.
Okay. Uh, hey guys, my name's T Lewis.
We're gonna get started tonight. I think.
Uh, we're gonna do a song at the beginning,
but, um, we do that.
I like before we get started. Thank you, uh, father.
Um, it's good to be here
with brothers and sisters in Christ.
Um, we thank you that we get to be in your presence
for your son, or thank your father that you have
torn the veil that you have opened,
opened a way for us to be in a right relationship with you,
to know you even when we didn't deserve it.
So Father, tonight, as we study who you are, help us to be,
um, invigorated father, help us to,
uh, be excited about that.
Help us to, uh, have a desire to know you more
and more prayer.
Amen. Alright, so Mark's going to start the song
and, uh, we've all, we're all gonna stand to sing, right?
Yeah. Be Is this a singalong song?
Singalong. It's s single along Let
S sing song mark.
So the story is we bended on a song every week,
and I had a song, mark had a song, and we arm wrestle
and we decided to go song
Righteousness.
I
Amen. You guys can
see. Thank you so much. Great stuff.
That, uh, that's good stuff.
And, um, so Alan wrote with markers last week
and this week we have two markers.
We have a red marker and orange marker.
I pulled this one out first. Now I'm gonna test it out.
Wait, is that the one? Yeah.
So I said, wow, that's a good marker.
Now pull out this orange marker. You better watch out. Oh,
Yeah.
Anyway, we're only gonna use red markers.
That's not right. That's, um, love you guys.
So tonight we're gonna talk about God's existence
and his knowability.
We're gonna start tonight. I want you,
I hope you picked up your memory verse.
So the memory verse is Psalm 46, 10.
And, um, I wanted to start with this
because I think it kind of sets the tone a little bit
because for some of us, it's a busy week.
It's a busy day, and it's like, we gotta go to class.
But tonight we're just gonna learn about, we're gonna rest
and we're gonna be still and know that he has God.
Um, we're gonna study and enjoy his existence.
And, um, and we're going celebrate it
and, and praise in court.
So our, our verse is Psalm 46, 10 says, be still
and know that I'm, God, I'll be exalted among the nations.
I'll be exalted in all the Earth.
And, and really we want that
to be the end game on our study is
that God has exalted both in our hearts and minds
and then with our mouths as we go out to others.
And Psalm 46, 10, uh, comes at the end of, uh, a chapter
of Psalms that I love.
It's been important at several different points in my life.
Two of which I will tell you guys about just
so you can know a little bit more, um, about me.
I was, uh, in medical school in 2001 on September 11th
when, um, the Twin Towers were destroy.
And there were several of us that were part
of the Christian Medical and Dental Society group.
And there were several that, that weren't, were just around.
And we were gathered in the lecture hall.
Um, when that happened.
And it was as many of you, all of you who were around, uh,
remember, that was total shock and devastation.
And, and we saw the Lord and we rely on him to be our peace
and our comfort and our refuge and our strength.
And so we turn to Psalm 46
and we read Psalm 46 in that group.
And it starts off, as many of you know, God is our refuge
and our strength, a very present help and trouble.
Therefore, we'll not fear, though the earth gives way,
though the mountains be moved into the heart of the sea.
And so in that moment, uh, it felt like
the mountains were being moving into the heart of the sea
and things were crashing down.
Uh, but we knew that the ward was our
refuge and our strength.
And then we read on and we get to the end.
And then there's this peace, this message of peace
where God says, be still
and know that I'm, uh, in the midst of all this calamity,
I'll be exalted among the nations.
I'll be exalted in all the earth.
And so, um, just as we jump into the study of who God is,
that's ultimately, he's our refuge.
He's our strength, he's our comfort and our hope.
And then, uh, fast forward a few years, um,
so I was doing medical school in
Texas, was married at the time.
Fast forward several years, we got moved to Oklahoma,
not part of the Lewis plan, part of God's plan.
And, um, found ourselves in a really neat community group
and, um, really neat community group, great friends.
And it was a time in our lives when our kids
were young and they were really busy.
And in 2006, if you remember,
we started Saturday Night Service at Henderson Hills.
And so our community group divided,
and half of us came to Saturday nights
and half of us stayed on Sunday mornings.
And, um, and so there was a,
most community groups are named
after whoever's leading the group, right?
So like the Smith Group or the Jones Group was Piper Group.
And, um, but our group decided,
I wasn't a leader at the time, uh, of, of that class,
but there were three couples
and they decided to name our class Pier 4 61.
That's interesting. Pier 4 61.
But they named it after Psalm 46 1.
I said, okay, why up here? He said, well, says
the Lord is our refuge
and our strength for very present health and trouble.
And for them that represented a refuge, a place to come
and heal, and a place to refuel for the journey.
And that's what appears when our ships at sail
and we're, we're out on the waters
and the waves are crashing in that, um, the Lord becomes our
refuge and our shrink and appear where we can dock.
But we don't stay at that dock forever, right?
We stay there for a period of time.
We come and refuel
and refresh, maybe clean the barn pools off the side
of the boat a little bit and we go back out.
So we saw that as a purpose for community
groups, uh, for us.
So as I, as I saw that, uh, mark had chosen Psalm 46
as a memory verse for this week, that really got me excited.
And, um, choosing
to follow Allen Rice was not part of my plan.
It just kind of happened that way.
But I have, I created what I call Allen Rice Bingo card,
which involved things like monkey crap
and other things
that Sean Connery is on the Ele Allen Rice Bingo card
and things you may have checked off throughout the week.
And so, um, as I came to,
I thought I need my own bingo card, Anita,
a TR Lewis bingo card.
But, um, I found a quote,
it's actually a passage I want read.
It's from Charles Spurgeon,
but it's from this, it's a quote,
it's actually a long passage that, um,
JI Packer includes in this book, knowing God.
So if you haven't read this book, I hadn't
read this book until this year.
And so I started reading it several months ago
and, um, really, really, uh, deep
and encouraging and insightful.
But this is a quote from Ch Spurgeon, the passage on opus
with, and this is from 1855, says,
it has been said by someone that the proper study
of mankind is man.
And I'll not oppose the idea,
but I believe that it's equally true, that the proper study
of God's elect is God.
The proper study of a Christian is the Godhead,
the highest science, the loftiest speculation,
mightest philosophy, which can ever engage the attention
of a child of God is the name, the nature, the person,
the work, the doings,
and the existence of the great God who he calls his Father.
There's something exceedingly improving to the mind.
And a contemplation of the divinity is a subject so vast
that all of our thoughts are lost.
And it's immense, so deep
that our pride is drowned in its infinity.
I'm gonna read that again. It's so deep.
God is so deep that our pride is drowned in his infinity.
Our subjects we can compass and grapple with,
and then we feel a kind of self content
and go our way with the thought.
Behold, I'm wise.
But when we come to this master science finding
that our plum line cannot sound its death,
and that our eagle eye cannot see its height, we turn away
with the thought that vain man would be wise.
But he is like a wild asses cult.
And with solemn explanation, I am but of yesterday
and know nothing, no subject of contemplation will tend
to more humble the mind than thoughts of God.
But while the subject humbles the mind, it also expands it.
He who often thinks
of God will have a larger mind than the man who simply pods
around this narrow globe.
The most excellent study for expanding the soul
is the science of Christ, him crucified
and the knowledge of the Godhead in a glorious trinity,
nothing will so enlarge the intellect.
Nothing so magnify the whole soul of man.
It is about as a devout earnest, continued investigation
of the great subject of the DAE.
And whilst humbly in expanding this subject is
imminently consolatory.
Oh, there is in contemplating Christ, a balm for every wound
and musing on the Father.
There is a quietness for every priest
in the influence of the Holy Ghost.
There is a balam for every soar. Would you lose your sorrow?
Would you drown your own cares?
Then go plunge yourself in the godheads deepest sea.
Be lost in his immensity
and you shall come forth as from a couch of rest,
refreshed and invigorated.
I know nothing which can so comfort the soul so calm,
so calm and swell buildings of sorrow and grief.
So speak peace to the winds of trial
as a devout musing upon the subject of the Godhead.
It is to that subject that I invite you to this morning.
And so it's with those words that we come.
So some of us need to be humbled tonight
by the study of God.
Some of us need to be encouraged
or expanded in our thoughts of God.
And some of us need to be consoled and comforted.
So we're gonna jump into the notes
and we're gonna study first the existence of God.
So I included this verse from Romans one
that many of us have heard.
It says, for what can be known about God has claimed to them
'cause God has shown it to them
for his invisible attributes, namely his eternal power
and divine nature have been clearly perceived ever
before, the creation of the world
and the things that have been made.
So there without excuse.
So tonight we're gonna try to look at this,
at this verse a little more deeply.
We're gonna try to study these truths in a deeper way
because we kind of come to the foundation tonight.
We come with the understanding that God does exist.
And many of us like me probably grew up that way.
Um, but we do have evidences of him all around us.
And God created us to yearn for him.
He created in us that spirit that wants us to yearn for him,
or at least create a man with that deficit,
that deficit in our lives that, that that is, that yearning
for something bigger than ourselves.
And so we'll talk about that as we go along the way.
And so it's in that, that we live
and we can really only see the world.
We only get to see the world through this lens that we live.
We get to see the world through the temporary.
But God is infinite. He's bigger than we can ever know.
And so it's with that, that we come tonight.
So our first point that we're gonna look at
is our inner sense of God.
So our first kind of idea of the existence of God is
that we have this inner sense of God.
And Gruden makes the argument in his book, um,
that all humans everywhere have an inner sense.
That God exists, an inner sense that there's a creator.
And you look around, you can say, maybe in my workplace,
maybe in my school, maybe in my family, there are people
that don't, they don't exhibit that.
We say everybody has that,
but they don't, they don't exhibit it.
And that's because we're a broken people. We're fallen.
It's like falses in, in Romans one,
that we're born into sin, we're born into aquity.
And it's because of that fall of Adam that, that
that's mask, it's jaded and that we can't see the right way.
And so in that perfect, in perfect creation where Adam
and Eve were created a perfect
relation, perfect unity with God.
So that's a natural part of how humans are made.
But we exist now in this broken form
and we exist that way until God pulls back the baby, right?
So we're illuminated by the Spirit to fully understand
and fully trust in God.
In John chapter 20, Jesus says,
have you believed 'cause have seen me?
So blessed are those who have not seen and yet believed.
Blessed are those who have not seen yet believed.
And so we, we go, we we're thankful for that tonight.
We're thankful that God has pulled back the veil,
but we understand that there are so many that have not.
And so in those verses in Psalms I have down there,
Psalm 14, one, um,
Psalm 53, 1 in Psalm 10, 3, 3 4.
And basically the gist of those verses, uh, David is writing
and says, the pool says in his heart, there is no God.
'cause those people are corrupt.
They do have vulnerable deeds. There's no one who does good.
The Lord looks down from heaven on the children of man
to see if there are any who understand any
who seek after God.
He writes, they've all turned aside together.
They have become corrupt.
There's no one who does good, not even one.
And so that speaks to our natural depravity, our depravity
of man that exists in this broken world.
And we see that. We see evidence of that, um, all around us.
But even in light of that, even in light of that, of,
of the folks that just reject God in all
of these different cultures all around the world,
Alan mentioned it a couple weeks ago, that
so many people groups have this idea of a divine creator.
You think about all the different world religions
and there's, there are tons of different creation narratives
that have been created over the years.
And we look back and there's a, there's that sense of
that yearning for a year, yearning
that's something bigger than ourselves.
And it, but it manifests in a variety
of different ways, right?
For some, they, they create idols out
of animals and, and creatures.
And some create an idol out of themselves.
Um, one of the, one of the things, one of the roles
that I do at the College of Medicine,
I teach 'em the humanities section.
I teach a spirituality and medicine course.
And so in that class, we kind of explore the different
manifestations of spirituality in different people groups.
And we study different formal world religions,
but also the idea of spirituality, the idea that as we come,
uh, as part of our human expression is this idea
that there's something bigger than ourselves
and that desire to be a part of it, right?
If you think about these world religions, that there's a,
there's an innate desire to relate to our creator.
And, and we see that in, in these ancient civilization.
What happens when you go to, to Central America
or to South America, the Asian,
you see ancient ruins or even in Rome.
What, what are those ancient ruins typically
of Deities?
They're deities are temples of places of worship, right?
So all throughout history,
these civilizations have created these things
that have stood the test of time.
There have been an idea to worship something.
And so we would say that, that that idea, the idea that
we have this innate inner sense
that there is a God isn't evidence of his existence.
And we'll, we'll talk more about that as we go on.
And the power that, um, the, the next kind of point there
that not only have all people kind of created these ideas
of worship, of a, of a deity, but,
and we see people turn to that in times of need, right?
In times of crisis, in times of need, that inner sense
of something bigger than yourself is exposed.
And in Christianity, sometimes we call
that coming to the end of yourself.
But people who don't have a box for that, like they,
they're seeking something there.
The quote is, there's,
there are no atheists in foxholes, right?
It's a quote that gets, it gets thrown around.
And it's the power, the power that
God has in his existence is exerted in those moments
of crisis, even in the lives of those who reject him, right?
Even in the lives of folks that that would say,
I don't, I don't believe in God.
I don't, I don't believe
that there even is God, I don't believe there's a creator.
But then when, when that strikes, it kind of forces
that a little bit, I think, to the surface.
And so, um, the last, the last kind of point in this idea
that this inner sense is this idea of logical arguments.
And so at the end of your notes, I included, I wanna come
to these at the end, but there's some really neat arguments
from, um, from Thomas client kindness
or client, the Proof of God existence.
So, we'll, we'll get to that, actually.
Let's go ahead and we'll walk through that.
We'll, no, we're not.
We'll go to that at the end. But, um, so we'll get
to those at the end of the evidence section.
But the second, second thing we come to is evidences
of God in nature.
So Romans one 20 speaks to this, that everything
that God created, he reveals his eternal
power and his divine nature.
And we see that in creation, right?
In Psalms chapter 19, uh, says,
heavens declare the glory of God
and the sky above proclaims his candy works.
We look up to the sky, up to an Oklahoma sunset, up
to a sunrise with the sea, the glory of God from day to day,
pours out speech from night to night where he's knowledge,
there is no speech nor their words,
whose voice is not heard.
Their voice goes out through all the earth
and their words to the end of the earth in them as a tent
for the sun, which comes out like a
bridegroom leaving his chamber.
Like a strong man runs its course with joy.
It's rising from the ends of the heavens
and it's circuit to the ends of, there's nothing
that's hidden from the seat.
And so if you can't look at the sky,
if you can't look at the heavens
and see evidence of God, then you're, you're missing it.
That to another, another part of nature that reveals,
uh, God is the complexity of the creation, right?
So I think about all the different complexities
of God's creation for, for, for each one of you
that may look different, right?
It may look like, um, a plant
that may look like, uh, a tree.
It might look like a hand.
Um, many riders have written about the
complexity of the human hand.
And if you look at all the ligaments and tendons and muscles
and nerves and everything, you just have
to work together in your hand to look at a hand
and say that, that wasn't divinely appointed.
Created. And then we look at the power.
We look at the power of God as evidence that he exists.
We see the weather, we see waters, the power
of water moving, the power of his creation.
We see the interconnectedness of God's creation.
That there are life cycles, life cycles in nature, right?
Life cycles in seasons that occur,
and that that's evidence of a divine creator.
And then we see beauty, right?
That all these things could have been made
and everything could have been brown, right?
But it's not right. Uh, or everything could have been made.
Everything worked perfectly except everything's flat,
but it's not right.
There are mountains and valleys
and there's, uh, there's beauty all around this
that God has given us, not only for our good
and for our enjoyment, but to, but because he could.
Right? Uh, and and it doesn't just happen by accident
and it's intricate and it's grand and it's delightful.
And it calls us in to this idea of a creator.
And then in Genesis, we see, we see humans.
We see man as the pinnacle of God's creation.
And not only are we kind of the pinnacle
of physical creation with, with an integrated structure
of our bodies from all the organ systems that work together,
but woven into that is a soul
and woven into that is a mind
and woven into that is a will
that God has uniquely created
and put an image, put a portion of his image
of himself inside of us.
And we have tastes, we have little, little tastes
of his attributes in us as we are little images of Him.
And so we in a way are in evidence of God in this world.
And that's, that's so beautiful.
But, but that realization that the way that we can see that
as followers of Christ is different
'cause we have that failed pull apart.
It's different than those who still are
walking in brokenness.
Because in our, in our redemption
and our rebirth, we receive the spirit that allows us
to see things differently, allows us
to appreciate creation in a different
and very beautiful way.
But God restores our ability to see him in all things
and to proclaim the excellencies of his creation.
And I was thinking several years ago, we had a,
we had a memory verse with a sermon series
of First Peter two, nine.
Do you mind know first Peter two nine? Do you remember it?
No. I put it in my notes and I can read it.
Brenda knows it. What is it?
Juror of chosen race, A royal priesthood, a holy nation
of people from his own possession that he claim
Into marvelous life, just like Chris Thomas.
And so he has called us out darkness. It's in that darkness.
So we can't fully appreciate the magnificence
of his creation.
We can't fully appreciate the existence
of God apart from him calling us out,
apart from him shining his light in,
if then he doesn't leave us there, right?
He doesn't. He, he uses us as an example.
We're called to proclaim the excellences.
I love that phrase. Proclaim the excellencies of him.
And Gruden, Gruden, GRU, in his book, the Big thick book
that's right over there, if he writes this, he says,
everything that exists gives, gives evidence
of God's existence.
I think about that. Everything that exists gives evidence
of God's existence for those who have eyes to see
and evaluate the evidence correctly.
Every leaf on every tree, every blade of grass,
every star in the sky,
and every part of all creation, cry out.
God made me, God made me, God made me. That's right.
So from the trees to the flowers, every we can see it,
we can see it 'cause our eyes are open
and we're called to proclaim those excellences.
And of course, we see evidence of God in scripture, right?
So we just spent two weeks talking about the foundation
that the word of God is the foundation
for our understanding of God.
And every chapter, every book, every verse
is predicated on God's existence.
And we see that from Genesis chapter one,
because it begins with the works of God.
And you can't have actions without existence, right?
Car can't drive if it doesn't exist.
God can't create if he doesn't exist.
So God can't make the heavens
and the earth if he doesn't exist.
So the very exist, the very actions of God
tell us about his existence.
And then our preface last week on the a errancy award
of God means that his existence is foundation to scripture.
And scripture is foundational. His existence.
What do I mean by that? Well, that scripture,
all the things we learned about
over the last two weeks, right?
The inerrancy of scripture, the, the sustenance of scripture
through the millennia, through centuries is evidence of God.
He's doing that work. And so he's evidenced in his word.
And so then we come to this last section, these proofs
for the existence of God.
And so these are some fancy words
and uh, had to learn some new words.
And, uh, and then these,
but these are, these are kind of four
and there are more in this last section,
and we'll read through these really
quickly and then jump to that last.
But it says, proofs for the existence of God.
So first is the, what's called the cosmological proof.
So that every, the, the idea
behind this is every known thing has a cause, right?
So there's a, if something's happening, it's
because something caused it to happen.
And so that we live in a great universe, right?
We can look outside, we can stand on the porch
with our buddy and say, that's a great universe, right?
And if there's a great universe, it's
because of a great creator.
That's the argument, the cosmological universe.
The next is the teleological argument.
It says, design gives evidence of intelligent purpose.
So that's the argument that would say, okay, if you find the
quintessential, as you find the wrist watch
laying on the beach, right?
You pick up that watch
and say, man, that watch didn't get there by accident.
Somebody had to make that watch, right?
And, uh, and a watch is a very finite, but very intricate,
but also a limited thing.
So to look at all the other creation, like I said,
and see that the, the design of purposeful design
of it, that the end goal
or purpose of a thing is evidence of the purpose behind it.
And it can only have purpose if we God
who created all things.
Next is the ontological argument.
This is very interesting
that God is a beam greater than which
nothing can be a match.
Okay? So we're gonna say if, if there is a God, God is,
God is greater than everything to say capital G God.
God is greater than everything.
And if God is greater than everything, then God must exist.
Because to exist is greater than not existing, right?
So if, if you wanna make another
argument, I only have to help you.
So if, if a thing is greater,
it's gonna be the greatest thing.
God's gonna be the greatest of whatever thing it is.
And if you have two options to not exist,
or two exist to exist is better.
We would agree that, yes.
So that's the oncological argument. We can get into that.
And then the moral argument, I love this one
'cause the moral argument kind of speaks to our soul.
It speaks to God, um, his, his personal breath of life kind
of into our lives and some of the evidence of him in us.
And the moral, moral argument is from the sense of right
and wrong that we have.
But there's a morality that exists.
The CS Lewis wrote about this
and your, your Christianity, if you read that book,
if you have any, it's really good.
It says, conscience reveals to us a moral law
whose source cannot be found in the natural world.
And it does, it points us to a supernatural law giver.
So the fact that we have this innate sense of right
and wrong, we have a sense of justice that's in us
as people is evidence of a God who is moral and just,
and there are several other men throughout years,
one named Johnson Newman, who made the point kind
of expand on it and says
that even we see in man an extension of
that moral law living by
that moral law even when it's not in our
best interest, right?
So, uh, uh, an animal might do
what is always in its best interest
'cause they don't have a, a moral inclination, right?
But our moral inclination in ourselves
to do what's right even when it doesn't benefit me at
all, right?
That is evidence of God, a God who is creator,
who is perfect in loving.
And so Gruden goes on to make the, he makes the argument,
uh, in his book, that departure from these,
uh, arguments
or from these proofs doesn't indicate
that the proofs aren't valid,
but rather proves that there's false assumptions
or incorrect reasoning, meaning.
So somebody argues with this, it it is
because their, their heart is not able to see,
or they're starting from, from a bad position.
So let's jump over real quick, um, to these,
to these Thomas a clients,
because I, I stumbled upon these,
I were like proofs of God existence.
So the first wave of motion, so these are kind of extensions
of some of these same, same arguments,
but this is the first one he, he wrote about.
And so it was, his arguments are these all bodies are either
potentially motion or actually motion.
And, and you have to be in either one that
to be reduced from potentiality to actuality,
except something in actuality.
So it sounds like physics, right?
Nothing can be at once actuality and potentiality.
It has to be one or the other.
And so, um, nothing can be at once, both actuality
and potentiality with respect to motion.
And so therefore nothing can move by itself,
but it must be put into motion by something else.
Okay? So there's the idea of something's moving,
something had to put it in motion.
And so our universe is in motion,
so we must say someone put that in motion.
Number six is if there were no first mover,
there would be no motion number seven.
But there is motion. So we can look around.
That's a, that's like an observable fact, right?
There is motion, therefore there must be a first mover.
So it'd be like a first mover argument.
So there is God, the second argument that, uh,
Thomas Quins makes is that of efficient cause, okay?
And it says nothing is the efficient
or nothing is affected by itself.
Nothing is the efficient cause of itself.
So if a, is the cause of B, if A is absent,
then B is also absent you on that.
It took me three times to read. So if,
if A makes B, if there's no A, there's no B, alright?
And so if there is no first cause,
there can be no ultimate effect.
But there are effects, there are things that are happening.
There is creation.
And so there must be a first cause of all of those things.
And that first cause is got, there had to be something
that kicked all this stuff off, right?
So that's the argument of a fishing policy.
The third proof of God that he puts out is
that a possibility and necessity.
So these get a little bit trickier,
but you may have to read it more as you get,
I'll read it here four more times.
He says, we find in nature of things that are possible to be
and not to be, okay, contingent beings,
everything is either necessary or contingent.
Assuming that everything is contingent, it is possible
for contingent beings always to exist for
that which cannot be at some time is not.
Therefore by three and four at one time there was
nothing, okay?
And that which does not exist against to exist only
through something already existing.
So this is where it kind of gets good with creation, right?
That which does not exist begins to exist only
through something already existing.
So therefore, if you take five and six
and put 'em together, then you come to the logical,
but there is nothing now.
So if there's nothing that started this thing off
and there's nothing now, well that's not very,
that doesn't make any sense because we get to seven and
or get to eight and eight says what?
There is something now.
So if we, if we believe eight is true, we look around
and we say there is something now
Brad says, yes, there is something.
Now there's grass outside,
there are trees, there is something.
Now then those other things are not true.
Therefore number three is false, right?
Everything is not contingent.
Some things are necessary,
therefore there is a necessary being that sort
of the necessary being is God.
So basically the argument he's making that is out
of all things that are possible, there had
to be one necessary thing.
Everything had to start from something
and that something is God.
God is the only being that fulfills all
of those other things that can be necessary in the
creation of everything else.
You guys are gonna have some good reading. Okay?
The fourth is radiation. So I like this one.
There's a gradation to be found in things.
Some are better than others, okay? That's true, right?
Some people are taller than me, lots
of people are smarter than me.
Things are X in proportion to how closely they resemble
that is, which is most X.
Okay? Who is the most bald?
That's the paper, right?
But there are different degrees of baldness, right? Okay.
So that's the argument. Therefore,
if there is nothing which is most X,
there can be nothing which is good, okay?
So it falls that if anything is good,
there must be something that is most good.
So if any attribute that you can think of, there's something
that is the most bad thing, okay?
If there's any happiness,
there's something that's the most happy.
If there's any joy, there's something that's the most joy.
And his argument in this is if there
is anything that is good.
So look it for if there's anything that is good,
there must be something that is the most good.
Therefore there must must also be something which is
to all beings the cause of their being, goodness
in every other perfection.
And this is what we call God, that God is that end
of the road argument.
So if there, if there is such a thing as purity,
God is the most pure.
If there is such a thing as love, God is the most loving.
If there is such a thing as goodness,
God is the highest of every single thing.
To have a, to have a thing, you have to have most,
you have gradation.
And then the last is design.
So he rights, we observe that natural bodies
act towards an end.
So the things in nature work towards an
end, work towards a goal.
And anything that acts towards an end either acts out
of knowledge or under the direction
of something with knowledge.
Okay? So either a thing directs itself, okay?
Or there's, there's knowledge
or there's design behind the thing.
So the example is an arrow, right?
The arrow is directed by something that's an arrow,
doesn't have knowledge of where it's going,
but the arrow is directed by the archer.
But many natural beings lack knowledge, okay?
Therefore, some intelligent being exists
by whom all natural things are directed to their end.
And this being we call God.
So that there is, because there is direction in
the world, we look to the source of where
that direction came from.
And we say that direction is got.
So these are, these are arguments that, so Aquinas,
as Alan taught me, was, was a study of Aristotle
and he was Aristotelian, is that correct?
Aristotelian, I'm putting that on my bingo term, right?
So it's Aristotelian.
And so he's using these logical arguments, he's walking
through this existence of God in a very logical way.
So if you take time and kind of mentally wrestle with those,
um, to kind of come to a little bit more about the
existence of God, okay?
But we're gonna jump to his knowability
and say, I know God, right?
Um, I wanna study a little bit more about that.
And, and, uh, one of the, one of the places I get to teach
and preach a lot is in our Spanish service.
And I like that because I'll say something
and then it gets translated in Spanish.
And so I get to learn and experience some of the words
and know, plus I only have to prepare half as much for the,
but in, in Spanish, there are two words
for the word to know.
So to know something there too, who knows those two verbs?
No. Say what is it? No, sir. Okay, you don't know.
That was one of 'em. No say that's right.
Say is a conjugate of ve, right?
So sve is the verb, which means to know information, right?
So, um, the other one is a verb called Kono.
So Kono is the experiential ledge of a thing.
Like, I've been there. I know, right?
So I think about Wichita, right? I've never been to Wichita.
I know about Wichita and I know it exists.
I know if you go on I 35 and drive 150 miles or
however far it is, you can get to Wichita.
So you'll say Wichita, right?
That's like a, that's like a meat.
He knows I know Wichita, right? But no, no school Wichita.
Like I've never experienced Wichita, I've never been there,
I've never gotten out 35
and drove up, never spent time there.
I don't really, in the barbecue joint,
I'm not missing anything, a zoo.
And so, so I don't know, I don't know the back streets,
I don't know the hangouts, but there are people
who have come, we should know it, right?
They know it. They've been there.
They got the t-shirt, they ate
the sandwich, they've been to Richmond.
And so the saying is true with God, right?
You can saber God, you can know things about God,
you can know lots of facts about God.
But what we are called to is to God, er,
to experience and to know him.
And that requires several things.
And so we're gonna study about that.
We're gonna talk a little about that. So first of all,
knowing God requires revelation.
So anything that we, that we learn
or we know about God, think about this.
Anything that we know about God comes through revelation.
Whether that's a sub knowledge or a sair knowledge.
And, and the, the way that we talk about that
is general revelation in special revelation
or fic revelation, special revelation.
So the general revelation, the things
that we can know about God, we can see, uh, some
of those logical arguments, we can maybe,
we could see that he's creator.
We can see the evidence of his creation.
Um, those are the, those are the saw bear things.
The, or the, the general revelation about God.
That's the Roman chapter one.
But then the, the, the that has to be revealed, right?
We, we don't get to that naturally, always in our flesh
so we can see it, but our, we can see it in our flesh,
but our flesh is broken, right?
So we need God for that.
But also this specific
or Sal revelation, it's experiential knowledge.
And that only comes to relationship with Jesus Christ.
Matthew 1127 said, no one knows the father except the son
and anyone who the son chooses to reveal him.
So that doesn't come through our own knowledge.
It doesn't come through our own wisdom.
Paul says at first Corinthians two,
he says in second Corinthians four, that our knowledge
of God, our how's that right?
Yeah. Of knowledge of God
and understanding that experiential knowledge
of God only comes through Christ.
He doesn't come through wisdom doesn't come through human.
Second point, God cannot be exhaustively or fully known.
We can't know everything about God.
And if we could know everything about God, then it wouldn't,
it wouldn't be God, right?
And so he's two, great.
And so I was thinking about people in scripture
who in scripture, two or three that we bumped up against
and figured out, I can't know everything about that
Som Joe, right?
Who else? David, right?
He, he said, I can't, can't know everything about God.
Psalms over and over and over where we read it.
And Paul, right? Paul in one Corinthians two says,
no one comprehends the things of God except
for the spirit of God.
And so like, we can't know everything about God.
And and so that can kind of produce two different,
two different reactions, right?
It can produce a, a defeatist type reaction
or produce a victorious type reaction.
So I included these verses, Psalm 1 45, 1 47, and 1 39.
So I'm gonna read the one, Psalm 1 45, 1 through six.
This is David's response.
He says, I will extol you, my God and king,
and bless your name forever and ever, every day.
I will bless you and praise your name forever and ever.
Great is the Lord and greatly to be praised.
And his greatness is unsearchable.
One generation shall come in your works to the other
and shall declare your mighty acts
o the glorious splendor of your majesty.
And on your wondrous works, I will meditate.
They shall speak of your might of your awesome deeds.
I will declare your greatness.
But this became a doxology, it became a praise to God.
And so he writes of it, he says, unsearchable or God's ways,
but what does he say he is gonna do?
He's gonna meditate, right? He says, it's unsearchable.
So he's saying, God can't know all this stuff,
but I'm gonna meditate on it.
I'm gonna try, I'm gonna work at it.
But then also I'm gonna share, I'm gonna speak of your might
of your awesome deeds and declare your greatness.
So we're not, we don't walk in this unknowability
or uns searchability in the thief and in victory.
Okay? Romans chapter 11, verse 33 is another passage
that speaks very beautifully to this.
And it's another, it's a, it's a Paul.
It's Paul reminding himself of praise.
And if you study Romans chapter 11 a lot, it's not easy.
It's a hard passage. And you can almost feel Paul wrestling
with someone this as he walks through it.
But then he reminds himself at the end of it, he says, oh,
the depth of the riches and wisdom
and knowledge of God, how unsearchable are his judgments
and how inscrutable his ways for who has known the mind
of the Lord and who has been his counselor,
who has given him a gift that he might be repaid or from him
and through him and to him are all names.
To him be the glory forever and ever. Amen.
And that's Paul's doxology at the end
of his hard teaching in Romans chapter 11, this hard writing
that he had to do is he just,
he finally says, I can't know it all.
Like this is really tough and I'm not gonna know it all.
And that's okay. 'cause God, you were greater and,
and I'm gonna praise you in that.
And then as I was studying this, I came across this,
this first from Joe.
There's one that I think grew included in his writings.
And it, it was one that I honestly hadn't, um,
spent much time with.
But he says, behold, these are the outskirts of his ways.
So he's like job's, realizing he's just skirting the edge
of everything that has to be known about God.
He says, how small a whisper do we hear him,
but the thunder of his power?
Who can understand that?
Wait, we get to hear the whisper,
but there's a thunder of who God is
that we can't even begin to approach.
And so I was thinking about, like, I, I, I,
I think I know a lot about a few things.
Like I know a lot about bones.
My son knows a lot about sharks. He really liked sharks.
So he studied all about sharks.
He can tell you all about sharks.
And it's fun to get together with people
who are like experts in a thing.
It's fun to kind of be an expert in a thing.
And we kind of geek out, we
call geeking out about those things.
So you give with somebody who like in a baseball cards
and they know a lot about baseball cards
and you can really have a real in depth discussion
about baseball cards, right?
But all those subjects, in reality,
you can get to the end of the thing.
You can get to the end of the thing,
but with God, you can't get to the end of the thing, right?
And so how good is it that we can get together
and geek out on the study and the knowledge of God, right?
That we, we, we, we can,
we can be intimidated by it, by so great.
But then it's, it's an infinite amount of, of experiences
for us to explore as we know them more and more and more.
And it's enjoyable to get to do that.
It's enjoyable to become an expert in those things.
Um, at, at Texas a
and m, we had a, a Tuesday night gathering that was called,
um, uh, can't remember what it was called.
It was really cool. We wish we
receivers, we wish we were receivers.
It was called Midnight Yell Practice.
But the, but the, the guy who taught
that was gonna have Greg Mot.
And so he told us one time he told us the story.
He was teaching us some of this argument,
but he was, he was explaining it with a game
that he would play with himself.
And so when he was walking through nature,
when he was hiking, he would look at a thing and,
and appreciate it towards greatness and his grander and say,
but God, you're greater than that thing.
Right? God, you're greater than that.
So that mountain, that mountain is really high.
I'm looking at Pikes Peak Pike Peaks really great.
Got notice on top of God, you are greater than Pikes Peak,
or I'm standing on the shore of the Pacific Ocean.
I'm looking out over the Pacific Ocean.
Those waves are really big and the ocean's really broad,
but God, you are bigger than that ocean.
And so we remember that, that he is, he's so big
and so massive and it can get, it can get, uh, a lot for us.
But we also remember that God reveals just the right that
for us at every, at every moment, right?
His revelation for us is sufficient.
And it's also just right.
Um, when I was in medical school, I worked
with a pediatrician when I was early
and the babies, the moms would come in
and say, my baby's throwing up,
my baby's spitting up their milk
and they can't handle it on school.
How big of a audible are you trying to give your baby?
And it was like a little baby.
And they were trying to give him like an eight ounce
bottle of, of milk.
And so he had this great thing, he would take the bottle
and hold it up next to the baby's stomach
and the bottle would be like,
bigger than the baby's torch set, right?
And the baby couldn't hold all that.
And so they couldn't, they couldn't keep it all inside.
But God knows exactly how much we can handle
of him, right?
How much we think about Moses, right?
When Moses said, God, I want to see all your glory.
God said, you ain't ready for that, bro.
He said, here's a, here's a little clip.
Do you hide in that clip? And I'm gonna, I'm gonna,
I'm just gonna, I'm just gonna do a drive by and turn right.
And, and so God knows how much we can handle
and he gives us just the right amount
and even more than than that of knowing God
that we can't know everything.
The next, the next kind of point is what we can know,
God truly right?
We, we, we kind of understand. We can't know him fully.
We can't know everything about God because he's infinite.
But we can't know him truly. So what do I mean by that?
Scripture is our true representation
of God's just the right amount.
It's objective, it's written by his hand
that we've studied not.
And that God's word is the surest
and truest expression of who he is.
And for all the reasons that we talked about over the last
two weeks, that's our avenue.
That's our glimpse into who God is.
And in, um, in, in Exodus 34, verse 6, 2 7, it says,
the Lord, this is, this is Moses when he says he wanted
to see God, and the Lord passed by before him.
And this is God's proclamation.
It says, I'm the Lord, the Lord.
A God, merciful and gracious, slow to anger and abounding
and steadfast love
and faithfulness, keeping steadfast love for thousands,
for giving iniquity and transgression and sin.
But Whoah, who will
by no means swear the guilty visiting the,
the fathers on the children, the children's children
to the third and the fourth generation.
And so in scripture, we have the ability to know God truly.
And every glimpse that we have,
if we see God is love, then guess what?
He's always gonna be loved.
And if we know that God is holy,
he is holy to the nth degree.
And so we get these little, these digestible
doses in scripture knowing that there's not more,
there's not something insidious
or different beyond that we're gonna learn in future, right?
'cause we know that, that God is fully true to himself.
He says that in his word.
And we see him prove himself over
and over again through the pages of scripture.
Next is we can know God personally. So we have this idea.
We can't know him fully.
We can know him truly in the scripture.
We can know objectively.
We can know what's right and what's not right about God.
But we also get the opportunity to know him personally
through connection through Christ,
through the revelation of the Holy Spirit.
That through the Holy Spirit we have this personal,
intimate relationship with God that Paul talks about.
Ephesians chapter one, right?
Um, in verse in verse 15 through 20, it says,
for this reason, I've heard your faith in the Lord Jesus
Christ, for all the saints, I do not cease to give thanks
to you for remembering me and my prayers.
And then, uh, later down the road, he says, um,
that you may know what is the hope
to which he has called you?
And what are the riches of his glorious
inheritance in all the saints?
And what is the immeasurable greatness
of his power toward us who believe according to the working
of his great mind, that we work in Christ
Jesus, that he raised from the dead.
That in Christ we have this personal relationship with God,
that we can have our own experiences,
but understand everything that we, there's a personal
experience with God is gonna line
up perfectly with scripture.
Right? It's that idea that God
won't reveal anything to us personally.
That's counter to his work. That's who he is.
He's consistent. And so we're called
to a closer personal relationship in prayer.
James chapter four says, draw near to God
and he will draw near to you.
And in John chapter 14, we get the idea
of God making his home with us.
And then, um, Christ has, has the teaching
of abiding in Christ through prayer that we can abide him
and we can know him,
but we can only know God through Jesus Christ.
Right? That's the only way.
That's the only way we can con stare at him.
'cause he tore that veil from top to bottom.
And that's, that's where the joy comes in this, right?
So there's, there's a lot of academia, there's a lot
of, a lot of study.
But then there's the joy
and the joy comes as we walk in the spirit, knowing him
and relating to him and relying on him.
And we say that, that he's given us grace.
God has given us grace to approach the throne of grace
and confidence, right?
That we can come to him in our times of need
and relate to him in a personal way to receive that, uh,
mercy and grace and the time of need.
We can ask for forgiveness. We need forgiveness.
We can ask for wisdom when we need wisdom.
And that, that promise that would come through Christ.
And so in all those other world religions
that we talked about and that we studied about spirituality
and medicine class, that we see
that all those fall short, right?
'cause in so many of God trying to make his way
to man the things that we're doing.
But we know that our true knowability,
when we think about the knowability of God,
that it comes through Jesus Christ.
It comes through that one source
that makes Christianity different.
Every other world of religion, every other expression
of spirituality, every other way.
That man has tried to build that void of God in his life.
Christ came to make that connection.
So we could have that, that deficit filled completely
and perfectly as our perfect propitiation
and perfect, um, perfect sacrifice for us.
And so we should appreciate that.
Everything that we can know about God, everything
that we can know about God, uh, intellectually,
but also everything that we can know experientially, is
because of the trying God,
'cause of God the Father through his word, God, the Son,
through his sacrifice of God, the spirit, his revelation.
So I hope that that, uh,
helps you guys understand the knowability of God.
Uh, David's gonna come
and have some discussion questions
for us when we wanna interact with some tonight.
And then, um, I've actually got one, one bit more,
but Mark's gonna close this out.
We're done. Okay. Alright. Thank you.
Tr I'm gonna get this outta the way
because I will end up knocking the I do not need,
and Mike have always been known as a dominant talker,
so you can probably always hear a little thing about me,
like trs, think a little bit about him.